joining us now thank you joining us now
is sophia bush an actress and activist
and host
of the podcast work in progress sofia i
am so happy to see your face
uh and to see that you are safe what can
activists like you
do to confront the dangers posed by
extremists and conspiracy theory
conspiracy theorists like marjorie
taylor greene who
i'm so annoyed saying her name why does
she have three names sorry i know i
think about that
and it's frustrating that we have to
talk about this
but it's very clear that not talking
about it didn't get us anywhere good
the explosion of these conspiracy
theories of q anon
of this virtual insanity online
is creating real and present danger for
americans
not just in dc but everywhere and what
frustrates me
about marjorie taylor green who claims
she's being silenced while fundraising
on
her lack of silence what frustrates me
about josh hawley who claims the same
and
i see him on a different talk show every
night saying he's been so silenced
is that they're acting as though the
rules do not apply to them
you cannot yell fire in a movie theater
it is against the law it is a dangerous
lie that will get people harmed and if
you do it you will be charged and you
will go to jail
for endangerment how is it that these
people do not think
that the lies that they are peddling
which resulted in an
insurrection that nearly
caused the assassination of a number of
our elected officials we were moments
away
from an unspeakable tragedy and they
think that this is okay
they think that this is just politics
that's not how
a civil society works and
it's honestly shocking to me that the
republican party is not asking these
people
to resign they have no place in public
life
it's really shocking to me too and i'm
rarely surprised
but i am shocked often um by the by the
lack of integrity and
and just the the the inability for
people to
recognize facts recognize the truth
the truth and facts are things that you
cannot manipulate
they are facts and truth like science uh
your podcast um i wanna talk about your
podcast
um now um your podcast focuses on how
people
successful in some areas of life
can keep growing and learning which is a
concept i love because my
therapist always says everybody has
something they need to work on
how did you decide to also use your
podcast to speak out on political issues
well the fun thing about creating a
podcast is that you really get to
interview anyone who fascinates you
and i realized through you know the
years you and i have known each other in
the
nearly 15 years that i've i've worked in
politics
and been an activist that there are
people who i have the privilege
of having conversation with that not
everyone has access to
so that was the initial jumping off
point i thought i can text gloria
steinem
doesn't everyone want to hear what she
has to say and
it was a great way to feel like i could
spend my privilege and also
be curious as a project and on top of it
as the election got underway it was an
amazing opportunity
to interview incredible on-the-ground
activists
working to make clear something which
should not be controversial
black lives matter and if we can agree
that they matter
everyone else's still matter things like
that
all the way to interviewing evan
mcmullen who ran
as a republican candidate for president
in 2016 and who is a firm
public voice against trumpism in the
republican party i don't just
talk to people i agree with i really
want to get down to
what you were referencing earlier the
brass tacks of the truth
because if we can agree that the truth
is our foundation
and from there we build from there we
have discourse from there we have debate
things will be okay but this sort of
false equivalency which was perpetuated
by the trump administration by
kellyanne's
alternative facts really created an
environment where people think
every opinion should be welcomed to the
table and the false equivalency
between the left who wants to pass
healthcare
and the extreme verging into fascist
neo-nazi right
who believes that america is only for
white people
and it should essentially be a
free-for-all for the wealthy these are
not
equal ends of a spectrum they are not
the same and we have to be able to agree
on that
if we're going to move forward
certainly not in democracy one of them
is completely anti-democratic
um and so you know sticking to the facts
and having a debate
based in reality you can have your
conservative point of view
somebody could have a liberal point of
view but you come to the table
in the same universe um and and move
from there
one of my favorite quotes is as long as
you live keep learning how to live
which i try to do every day because i am
so far from perfect so we're just always
trying to work on on ourselves
what are some of the things you've
learned from your podcast about how to
keep growing
and learning every day well
one of the things that's been so
illuminating for me and that's been fun
to share with the audience
is that ever widening
sort of purview you know being able to
jump into so many people's perspectives
hear where they come from hear why they
believe what they believe and how they
were raised to learn about other
people's cultures
those are the things that have always
fueled me and in a way i
feel like i've been able to take that
passion
and really grow it and what it always
reminds me to do
is to take a step back and analyze
someone's feelings thoughts and
behaviors i i will always believe that
we need that
you know nicely poured foundation of our
house which has to be built on truth
um but i i want to know why people think
the way they do
and i think being willing to
learn information and when you learn
something new being willing to change
your mind
that's an incredibly important thing to
hold on to and
i'm consistently reminded through the
podcast that there's always new things
to learn
always new perspectives uh to
to be in conversation with and and when
we can do that i think it really keeps
us
kind keeps us generous and if anything
it has made me
even more fierce in my conviction for
justice
because justice is unequivocally rooted
in love and generosity
absolutely i feel driven by that every
day
i get that from my mama uh what are some
of the things you personally feel like
you're still learning how to do
i'm still learning how to be patient i
don't know
there's others but what about you
um i'm still learning to not take things
personally
you know it's it's a strange thing to as
i know
you do as well when you've got this big
platform
there's just one of you but there's a
lot of people
you know sort of coming in through that
bottleneck and
and it can be hard to be a container for
so many opinions and so much criticism
um so i'm i'm really trying to learn
you know what is mine and and what stays
on the outside
but i'm sensitive so that is a little
tough for me
i'm i'm also trying to learn
what it means to create practices for
myself that
i have to be this sort of accountability
buddy for
because it's so difficult you know
whether it's
uh eating the things i know i should to
keep my asthma in check
or you know a stillness or meditation
practice whatever it is we're all
supposed to be doing in this sort of
panoramic stress that we're experiencing
collectively
i keep trying to do these things and i'm
like this is really hard
so you know right what are you gonna do
yeah
yeah i do know i know don't take things
personally that is good advice
thank you so much sophia bush for being
here tonight
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching